well i want to get to that but you bring
up a very fascinating point
to me your liberal friends
you know you're you're died in the wool
liberal or your mainstream middle
they have made what we're dealing with
possible yep
because they've never stood up against
it
and now they're being threatened by it
like everybody else
uh some of them see it bill maher and
some of these other people naomi wolf
although she's not a liberal she's a
radical but nonetheless they see it even
glenn greenwald sees it he's
left with people are saying uh oh
yeah uh oh you remember stalin went
after trotsky
these people are not nice i mean mal
wiped out all of his lieutenants this is
the way it goes
how worried are you though that with you
mentioned big tech that with the
acceleration of information
that by the time say we get to the
midterms the amount of destruction
that these guys will be able to do
whether it's packing the courts
changing the electoral college
immigration
i mean the litany of things that i know
you're worried about that it will be too
late that in some ways that the founding
documents won't even be able to stand up
to it because there
is a wash coming that that seems
oddly unstoppable
it's a great point a lot of the
firewalls in the constitution have been
breached
it's been a long time coming i've
written about it over the course of 20
years or so
they've been breached by the courts
they've been breached and so committee
you know c-o-m-i-t-y that sort of thing
used to exist you know you run an
election you lose all right i lost
now there's another election coming now
the game is with the number
i lost an election i never intend to
lose an election again
[Music]
and your question is do we have time i
don't know
but we need to fight like hell because i
can't i don't know what's going to
happen in two years five years and six
years i know it'll happen
if they win and we lose it's going to be
totally different country and people are
going to be
sending their kids through
indoctrination mills and all kinds of
terrible things are going to happen in
this country where people probably still
don't believe it's possible it's
possible it's happening
and that's one of the key things people
need to understand this isn't theory
this is reality it is here and now this
is going on
this is repression that's taking place
people it can't happen in america
it can happen anywhere and you know
we've had we had these firewalls in
place
many of them have been breached many of
them are controlled by the wrong people
and so that's the reality and we have to
push back and do everything we possibly
can
is the fundamental problem that the
firewalls only work if we can sort of
agree that the rules are the rules and
now we're fighting
something that doesn't agree that there
are rules or or that the rules were set
up by evil patriarchal racist
you know whatever you want to call it
you hit the nail on the head
freedom without virtue doesn't you know
it's not freedom and
that was exactly what the founders said
you can't just have freedom you have the
people who are going to follow the rules
you have to have people who are going to
have integrity
you have the people who don't want to
burn down the place you know so
you have an election fair election you
win you lose
okay next election it's not i'm going to
change all the rules
to make sure i win and if you don't
agree with me you're a jim crow racist
so the democrats have decided to take on
the
posture and the substance of the most
radical elements within the party
and that's why you say you know you
watch
this chauvin case and you watch the
riots and everything and you watch
either the silence of the democrats
or the celebratory tone of the democrats
and even though black lives matter and
antifa
aren't official wings of the democrat
party in many ways the useful idiots
of the democrat party and vice versa
they feed off of each other
the democrats need to stir the pot
they want their base to be angry they
want their base to coalesce around them
they want to use the opportunity to
change the country whether it's the
voting system whether it's the
immigration system whatever it is
and that's exactly what they're doing
and so
when you hear what biden said a couple
of days ago
after uh the verdict you know this shows
america systemically racism
who the hell are you talking to what do
you mean america's systemically racist
i'm not chauvin i don't even know what
the hell you're talking about you don't
even know what you're talking about 40
years ago you were white supremacist
now today you're telling us we're all
he's a very evil man who's always been
about joe biden and so forth then i
watch kamala harris get out there and
say
the nation's systemically racist
i don't need to tell you but to
underscore the point
there are millions of people trying to
get into this country yep
they're not coming from sweden they're
not coming from norway
they're coming from central and south
america they're coming from africa
they're coming from the far east they're
coming from
asia these are minorities these are
people of color
by the millions they want to come into
the united states because we're
systemically racist
i mean how absurd is this whole debate
and mark none of them are leaving this
country
it's an it's a very confusing thing
let's let's back up to biden for a
second because
i had i still have a couple friends uh
who are liberals that will still talk to
me some most mostly privately they won't
talk to me publicly anymore
but a lot of them kept saying don't
worry dave after the election don't
worry
biden is the firewall they didn't go
crazy bernie
they didn't go crazy elizabeth warren
biden will stand up against this stuff
and now that trump is gone
it will be easier for us good liberals
to fight the woksters well in the few
months since this has all happened i
have watched these people
fold like a wet paper bag did you have
any illusions
that biden might stand up to some of
this stuff or did you just fully
believe that he was going to go down
this route no matter what well i want to
get to that but you bring up a very
fascinating point
to me your liberal friends
you know you're dying in the wool
liberal or you're mainstream liberal
they have made what we're dealing with
possible yep
because they've never stood up against
it
and now they're being threatened by it
like everybody else
uh some of them see it bill maher and
some of these other people naomi wolf
although she's not a liberal she's a
radical but nonetheless they see it even
glenn greenwald sees it he's
left with people are saying uh oh
yeah uh oh you remember stalin went
after trotsky
these people are not nice i mean mal
wiped out all of his lieutenants this is
the way it goes
right they're not just coming for levin
anymore now they're looking at me yeah
the french revolution raspier he went
after everybody and then he got the ax
so the revolution is a nasty piece of
work
but we still don't have the liberals
they're either completely silent
or they just think this is another cycle
we're going through and so forth will
all come out of it just fine
we need the liberals we need to unite
we need to have people who aren't them
the marxists who are trying to destroy
this country
we may have uh disputes over this little
issue or that little issue
but if you love this country put the
damn disputes aside we've got to unite
against this they are attacking
every aspect of the bill of rights are
unalienable rights they are attacking
businesses they're attacking minorities
they're attacking
private property rights they're
attacking our free speech they're
attacking freedom of assembly go down
that list
and it's happening very very fast as as
you point out
as for biden wait can we stay
can we just stay on that for just one
second because because i'm fascinated by
this and as you know i wrote a book
defending
liberalism but do you think that there
is a fundamental
flaw in liberalism that has stopped
these people from doing that because
that's the uncomfortable conclusion
that i've come to at this point to me
the flaw is look what you did was very
brave
but you could live with yourself you
said you know what i'm over here
but there's too much weird stuff going
on over here i don't agree with all this
it's too weak we're losing this we're
losing that i gotta move over to some
extent with these other guys who get it
i don't have to agree with them on
everything but fundamentally
they're civil libertarian i'm a civil
libertarian yeah i believe in civil
rights i believe in individual liberty
that's what i believe in
the the left believes and group this
group that even liberals
we don't even see the aclu anywhere
anymore where the hell is the aclu
they're in on this now it's not that we
don't see them they're in on it yeah
and that's the thing so to me what
liberals
traditional liberals have done is
they've made it easier
for the hard left the marxist left
they've helped pave the way
for them and i think some of them don't
know what to do about it it's like well
i don't really want to say that the 40
years i've lived
are flushed down the toilet that's the
other hand these other guys are kind of
ugly
over here i don't know whether i want to
join them you know
and they're going to get rolled over
with the rest of us if they don't stand
up
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell